and then to hear
jess say that like she doesn't feel as
close or she feels like we might not
even be friends anymore because we're
like we don't ever ever talk i'm like
whoa we brought up love languages for me
it is quality time so i don't feel loved
if i don't get the quality time even if
the history is there even if like you
killed someone for me and you buried
them the body for me ten years go by and
i never saw you i wouldn't feel close to
you anymore it just starts to to add up
to me
as like oh i don't have anyone anymore
like you're not like i know we have this
history and it's really strong but then
sometimes it feels like oh you but i
really don't have you anymore like
someone else has you now like so i need
to move on dude i'm discounting this as
her being on her period because she does
some very hurtful things or something
[Music]
hello welcome back to big mood if you
missed our last episode that featured
all four of us i don't know what order
these are i'll just put these back
together these will be okay okay if
they're coming out back-to-back we
decided for this time to just play and
have one long conversation as if we're
all hanging out again for the first time
in five months because that is what is
actually happening
and it's actually more interesting when
we're talking off-camera we realized um
than when we start talking about our
topics so in a very structured manner
yeah in a very structured way so we're
like let's just [ __ ] continue this
conversation that we're having getting
ready for hours for yeah for four hours
and see what happens maybe people will
like that
more than the topics that we're trying
to do the views have gone down let's
just
try anything
i don't care about
these but i do care like if the purpose
of the show is like to invite you into
our little girl group we should do that
again i do want you guys to feel that
way and i think that this is the most
authentic way and we're just going by
the seat of our pants whatever we would
normally talk about that comes up in
conversation that's what we're talking
about and the last episode
what happened at the end was we started
talking about kind of like we touched on
friendship love languages because high
maintenance and low maintenance gina was
talking about high
high maintenance and low maintenance
friends and she said i'm so glad you
guys are all low maintenance oh not you
jess but well i said that
well yeah
and then we're like let's unpack the
next one so we have had a few
conversations about this recently and i
don't know maybe jessica wasn't there
you know
she's so she knows
she didn't leave the phone call we
stayed on the phone for like two hours
after you left last time
i have dinner plans with my actual
friends yeah
i'm so glad you guys are low maintenance
because i don't i don't need to be here
right now yeah yeah no it's the same
thing with my my actual friends like my
oh you're right
my actual real friends yeah you guys are
gonna see that my actual friends my
actual friends no my girlfriend that
i've had since like high school okay we
literally live two miles away from each
other and i see her like once every two
months right and then you know like i'll
make other friends who are similar and
then i introduce them to each other and
then they can babysit each other for me
you know so it's like if one wants to go
out and i can't it's like you don't want
to water your plants you want to have
plants and have like someone else
with your snake with pixel you had pixel
yeah but you had like can take care of
her and then uh cause i was traveling so
much so i need like gina's like i don't
have kids personally yeah i really am
absolutely like maybe i'm like if i have
kids i'm dropping them off at your place
every day kind of person so maybe you
just need like three or four nannies
that's exactly what i need yeah so like
i was talking to you know like my
friends about it because we were
discussing um high maintenance friends
who were always like i'm like my old
roommate she had to be on the phone with
her friends all the time they were
always on the phone thank you for saying
what a
high maintenance person is so how much
how how often does she need to be on the
phone
bro like ever like quantify this for me
and how many hours per day
all day
okay
yeah that you can take
know that you like that you couldn't you
would consider high maintenance oh high
maintenance yeah what's like so she's
saying this is extreme high maintenance
yeah what is normal high maintenance oh
basic requirements for a high
maintenance oh high maintenance to me is
like we have to be on the phone like
once a week
um i'm texting you all day every day and
you want to see me at least like once
every two weeks
that's that's a lot for me that's too
much for me i agree with you gina okay i
just don't i didn't want to say sides
but i've been using you in a lot of
arguments lately
so um anyway let's continue with the
descriptions
of what a what's an extreme low
maintenance friend you sound like the
extreme version of your happiness right
yeah what's like uh
the a center leaning low maintenance
center
yeah maybe like uh like the you know
just dip it in okay okay okay like just
like right in the middle of it all yeah
yeah uh it's like i'll text you here and
there we'll talk like a few times a week
on text i will rarely ever call
no i check in once a week
or twice a week
much time goes by that you think is a
week
i mean like i'm in like three different
you know four different group chats and
i check in only every once in a while i
miss full-on conversations are you are
your group text muted she didn't know
that i broke my finger until it was
already healed yeah okay see but i knew
that because i at least ghost i read
through them you read it don't respond
i read through them yes and then i'll
respond like i responded to your finger
being broken i was like holy [ __ ] and i
was like
i responded to your finger being healed
thank you i responded when it happened
you did yes tiff always responds first
responders
i think this is an interesting
conversation
my like emergency contact besides my
parents and my family if anyone needs to
be next i got you i actually i think
that this topic like even though the
emotions uh were there when we had this
conversation
originally um i do think it's a really
interesting topic that other girlfriend
groups might be able to relate to but no
one really i don't think talks i've
never heard anything because that's why
there was no standard set and that's why
we had to do yes you have different
expectations yeah absolutely like i um
i was talking to a friend recently we
made plans but last minute she had to
cancel no he had to cancel and i was
like that's fine and then he was like
dude thank you so much for being really
chill about me like canceling stuff with
them like yeah i know because i'm the
same way too you know but like
you didn't even get ready yet you don't
get ready
you're supposed to be there like so it's
it's i and when people cancel on me i
never get mad i'm like okay it's fine
next time you know because you're like i
wanted to sleep anyway thank you exactly
yeah like i'm so used to just being by
myself it's like no it's fine like when
people cancel plans i'm like yes
yeah
that's nice you know
um but you know like i don't come i
don't go completely in my a like i've
been trying to make it a point to
be there personally more often um
and i realize now lately i've been
having my social life has been a lot
more busy
which is like oh god i can't believe i'm
like
going out you know we're like the same
person yeah this is exactly my life
lately yeah and i
am like wow i've never really had this
much of a social life before yeah it's
been going on a lot i'm the one making
meeting people and making friends in the
city and steve's the one that i'm
introducing them to like usually it's
the other way around he makes all the
friends i'm the one like getting
introduced to and all this stuff but
yeah lately it's been like i've been
friends with all my neighbors but i was
telling jess how like when
like the way that we perceive closeness
is like i feel very close to you guys
even though i don't text you all the
time i don't call you all the time i
don't you know we're not like seeing
each other all the time i feel closer to
you guys than i would let's say my new
friends in vegas that i see almost every
other day yeah um yeah because we have
history because we have history and
memories and to me
that that
like creates more closeness in my heart
than
the amount of time spent quantity of
time means less to me than the quality
of time and the length that i've known
you for like the amount of moments that
we've had together compiled over time
and like the growth we've had as people
and like just all of all of that stuff
like seeing
life unfold and being there for like the
the good moments um but also i'm i was
talking about the i brought up gina's
version of low mid maintenance high
maintenance friends because i'm the same
way with all of my closest friends the
ones i feel the closest to
i see them maybe
four times a year yeah and uh we text
each other like every couple months
and those are the ones i feel the
absolute closest to so i text you guys
way more often and
and then to hear
jess say that like she doesn't feel as
close or she feels like we might not
even be friends anymore because we're
like we don't ever ever talk i'm like
whoa like i feel like i talked to you
guys more than oh yeah
my like closest closest friends
so yeah i don't know um it was an
interesting
i was surprised by it yeah but then we
got to talk well so i think a part of it
is that we definitely have like i guess
different ideas and then because nikki
was like well that's so high maintenance
like i see my friends like four times a
year blah blah and i was like when it
finally clicked for me was more recently
and we talked about this last night
where i was like
i have those friends too and gina is one
of them i never talked to this [ __ ] but
when i see her it's totally fine and i'm
not upset that i don't talk to her in
between
or that she'll go mia for like four
months at a time or whatever you know
it's just that i have
certain friends that i put on different
levels where i'm like oh i expect that
this person is close to me so they're
gonna be a part of my daily life and
that's like you're on a different level
so in my so i put you on a different
level than i would gina because like and
gina even knows like we don't see each
other all the time
we don't talk all the time so i guess
for me and then you brought up love
languages for me it is quality time so i
don't feel loved if i don't get the
quality time even if the history is
there even if like you killed someone
for me and you buried them the body for
me ten years go by and i never saw you i
wouldn't feel close to you anymore
because we didn't get the quality time
anymore so i'm actually service in
quality time but i feel like quality
time means like when we're together we
have quality time like we're not just
like in separate rooms on a phone like
yeah we're like together
right and so like it's not a amount of
time like it's not like i have to see
you daily having quality time it's like
the times that we do get together are
quality and so it was it was just
interesting to me because
yeah i don't really talk to anyone yeah
um i'm like alone like gina like i'm
just alone so much um studying playing
poker reading um
it's funny because like the out of the
four of us there's like two of us that
are more extroverted and two of us are
more introverted and then we kind of
flipped because me and jess are the more
extroverted out of the four of us and
we
i'm i'm not sure about you jess i don't
want to speak for you but at least for
me like i don't see anyone like i'm just
at home with luca and with casey and
with isaac and i have like zero social
life yeah and then you guys end up
having like the most social it's really
funny yeah it's kind of flipped right
now and i also feel like i'm in the
middle of both of you guys and
i feel like they're the extremes yeah
right they're the most high maintenance
and she's the most low maintenance and
we're
your center leaning high and i'm
centered
yeah so i i think previously nikki was
kind of like trying to define what is it
that you need in order for like our
friendship to be fulfilling for you and
i would and i was like well i mean i'd
like to talk to you more than once every
few months like and then i even told
tiff i was like can we talk like every
other week or every two or three weeks
or something just like check in with
each other and tiff was like yeah of
course and nikki's like oh you know like
that's a lot i don't even like being
like funny
if we're all living in the same city and
we're like hey let's get brunch next
weekend i'm like hell yeah yeah i'm down
but if it's like you're in a different
country or not different different
cities
you're in different state i'm in a
different state they're in a
state together but state of depression
is different
i'm gonna state a depression
um we're not getting we're not like
having a quality in my mind it's not
quality time to be on the phone like i
don't like being on the phone i think
it's really draining for me i don't
unders like i don't know when i'm
supposed to talk i don't see facial
expressions so i'm not absorbing as much
information on a facetime not really no
because i'm holding it yeah i'm holding
it and it's like the it's always going
in and out like yeah i'm not people
i'm not a fan of facetime neither so i
get that yeah we were on the phone yeah
like me and tiff talk on the phone for
like three hours at a time
to me and it goes by so
steve is the same way so he'll talk to
the phone with someone for like three
hours and then he'll get off the phone
call someone else
okay put this in perspective i just i
live like an hour away from my dad and
i'll still call my dad and talk to him
for an hour oh wow that's cute like
yeah so for me i think it was just like
when we first started hanging out
together more we were like working
together living closer to each other we
had a lot of social activity so in my
head i put you as oh this is the person
that's going to show up for all these
things who's always going to be there
who's going to be texting me constantly
and like calling all the time because
like that's kind of like just how life
was in that yeah
yeah and then so then like when things i
guess went back to quote-unquote normal
or things just started moving in
different directions and i was like oh
wow like i guess she really doesn't want
to hang out with me anymore or something
like and then you're like oh no that
just naturally like i only i'm only with
what's in front of me yeah like i'm busy
and what's in front of me and that's it
and that's what it doesn't take away
gina and i maybe have the social lives
right now because
we are very much like whatever we're
into at that point in time that's who
we're spending the most time with so for
me i'm i'm not even spending a lot of
time with steve anymore like with poker
groups i'm like playing poker a lot and
with our neighbors who live literally
next door and like they also play poker
yeah so it's like kind of out of sight
out of mind for you a little bit yeah
yeah like when i'm doing an activity i'm
just there i'm very present in whatever
i happen to be doing and so if
if you're not there too like i'm just
spending time with whoever's there right
now doing the thing that i'm doing that
i'm also passionate about and they're
also passionate about yeah when i but
then when you go home you don't really
think like i don't think about that when
i go home okay yeah when i go home i'm
not thinking like i want to go see them
again i'm like thinking about the next
thing i'm doing i'm like okay i gotta do
my nails and then i got a shower and
then i meditate oh i wanna watch that
youtube video on blah blah and then like
i have this list of things that i'm like
thinking about i'm also not thinking
about talking to anybody um but then if
you were to text me and you're like hey
this weekend i want to do this or i'm
coming to vegas i'm like okay cool so
when you're here you have my full
attention yeah we're going to dinner no
i don't believe that i do yeah yeah and
so i'm not talking i'm not thinking
about my poker friends when i'm at
dinner with you you know it's like
whoever is there in front of me and
we're spending quality time together
they get my full quality time and love
and then i guess the way i gauge
closeness is by who's had more of those
moments who have i like opened up to
more who knows more of like the deeper
version of me not just like surface
level passions because like my poker
group that i sometimes see at casinos
they don't know me know me like we talk
about hand histories we talk about poker
but they don't like they haven't had
moments where they saw me cry they
haven't seen me at my worst they weren't
showing up at my door where i thought
like the world was ending you know like
you have been so
that's acts of service first of all for
me and so that went in my book strong
and then also whenever we have hung out
it's been very quality so you like hit
very like strong notes of friendship for
me so you go in my book as like very
close and like them even though i see
them more and i'm spending time with
them they don't they don't have those
moments they didn't bank those
those like friendship coins so when i
break the piggy bank there's like two
cents in there when i bring your piggy
bank there's like hundreds of thousands
of dollars in there yes thank you yeah
thank you there's a bentley in there
yeah absolutely absolutely anyway i am
too yeah i think i just i wait because
we had as more context to this we had a
conversation and i was like i just feel
like yeah like we're not even friends
anymore nikki was just like really taken
aback by that but i think i get what
you're saying now yeah but like for me i
was like well if we never talk or like
if i i even texted you one day when i
was kind of going through something and
you're like oh i'm at a tournament like
i can apply tomorrow and i was just like
god damn it like i really need somebody
right now and then just if months go by
where we don't really talk
it just starts to to add up to me
as like oh i don't have anyone anymore
like you're not like i know we have this
history and it's really strong but then
sometimes it feels like oh you but i
really don't have you anymore like
someone else has you now like so i need
to move on
yeah you know yeah it's really i mean i
understand now too because at the time i
was like dude i'm just counting this as
her being on her period because she
she's doing very hurtful things or
something she's like part of it i don't
know i was like wow she really thinks
we're not friends after all we've been
through that's crazy to me i'm like yeah
she's this she's got hormones i'm not
even going to count that as real gesture
but i mean imagine and we want to talk
about it more if you're in a
relationship with someone right like you
and casey like if you guys kind of just
stopped talking over the course of four
months and like you just hung out with
your friends all the time and he was at
work or hanging out with his friends all
the time
you would be like well yeah we have this
history we're married what else do you
want from me and i would be like well to
talk to you more often like because i'm
actually growing into a different person
and i don't know if you're gonna be
there for it yeah yeah so but yeah i
just have a like a more of a when i let
you in i like hope that you'll be there
all the time too but then and because i
have demoted friends too where i'm like
i'll talk to you next year yeah like
whatever we'll catch up over a dinner
and then i'll see you again in two years
like whatever the [ __ ] but i just didn't
have you
on that level in my mind yeah so sense
yeah so i just started to feel like oh i
feel like i'm the the distance is turned
into like i relate to that yeah so when
you start on your health journey it is
easy to be overwhelmed by all the
information the wellness industry throws
at you but noom believes the only place
you really need to start with is your
mind okay because with new weight you'll
take a path toward better health one
lesson at a time their psychology based
approach helps you change the way you
think about food and health rather than
demanding you to change your entire
lifestyle do you know what i'm talking
about like so instead of you needing to
like wake up at six in the morning and
like look at your macros and go and
work out like high intense cardio and
weight lifting and all kinds of stuff
the crazy workout people do look i used
to do that too i still do sometimes it's
nice to break a sweat but you don't need
to is the thing a healthier life doesn't
mean sticking to rules about what you
can and can't eat doesn't mean being
really rigid doesn't mean having to
count calories newm's cognitive
behavioral approach focuses on why
instead of what to help you change your
relationship with food so when i first
started with noom it had me keep a food
journal and you can kind of see like
sometimes you think you're only eating
meals but then you keep a food journal
you're like oh actually i ate a whole
bunch of potato chips i didn't even know
that we had potato chips but apparently
i consumed them and it was because it
was during this one stretch of time
where i wasn't even hungry but i was
super stressed out about work and i was
trying to procrastinate and i found out
very quickly that i am a
procrastination slash boredom slash
anxiety eater so every time i had one of
these things happen i subconsciously
reached for food and i didn't even know
about it and so knowing these things and
knowing that i also would do that at
social situations because i just was so
full of anxiety about talking to people
that i would always have to have a drink
in my hand or like have a have a snack
in my hand something to occupy my
my hands because i was just so filled
with anxiety i realized that that was
like a big leak in my wellness health
and wellness game so start building
better habits for healthier long-term
results sign up for your trial today at
noomnoom.com
big mood that's noomnoom.com
big mood to sign up for your trial today
whether it's a warm cup of coffee
basking in warm sunlight or listening to
a sexy story pleasure is all around us
with dipsy your sanctuary is waiting
escape into a world where pleasure is
your only priority dipsy is an app full
of hundreds of short sexy audio stories
designed by women for women they bring
scenarios to life with immersive
soundscapes and characters no matter who
you're into or what turns you on find
stories about that intriguing co-worker
with a british accent or hooking up with
your hot yoga instructor they even have
stories designed specifically to your
zodiac sign new content is released
every week so in between listening to
your favorite stories again and again
you can always find something new to
explore dipsy also has sleep stories
wellness sessions and now they also
offer written stories it's your go-to
place to spice up your me time explore
your fantasies or heat up things with
your partner for our listeners dipsy is
offering an extended 30-day free trial
when you go to dipsystories.com
mood that's 30 days of full access for
free when you go to dip d-i-p-s-e-a
stories dot com slash mood dipsy stories
dot com slash mood yeah like what you're
saying like i'm more centered but more
hype means so like
with this whole process of like
with luca being born which we talked
about too like because i was in that
same conversation that they're talking
about um
yeah i was like you know what i relate
to what jess is saying because i'm like
you know it's crazy that luca at that
point he was like what two months old
yeah i'm like he's two months old you
guys have never seen him not even
through facetime someone's like pictures
yeah i'm like i don't feel like we're
we're like you guys are like my bestest
friends which you are so i'm like i feel
i feel neglected too a little bit in the
friendship so i'm like i understand that
but then i also understand nikki's
perspective where it's like well i i'm
not trying to text every single day i'm
not trying to be yeah and that's fine i
know every single day that's a bit much
right or like because then now i have my
hands full weight yeah
and stuff
um but yeah like i totally understand
both perspectives for sure
i'm just gonna text once a week in a
group chat and i'm just gonna say i am
still your friend
[Music]
you know what that reminds me so in
casey
so i'm really really really bad at words
of affirmation and that's really
important to casey
so what i've been doing recently i am
still your wife no no i see moments i
see moments at like because like in
person right he'll be telling me
something and i'm like words of
encouragement
i love you
like i'm literally labeling it
because i'm like i'm sure that means so
much to you
that's not really what i was
and then i'm like hoping just don't know
what to say but at least like you have
like i'm telling you my intention i want
to do it yeah yeah you want to do the
effort i just don't know how to do it
i'm the same i can't think of a
validation
validation i love you he's going to call
me and be like i'm trying i called you
okay
and gina's gonna be like uh alexa set a
schedule
to text
i'm still your friend in the group chat
[Applause]
to
you could probably write a program that
would text something that seems a little
bit more genuine too
yeah yeah for nicki specifically i'm
just gonna set it like during like
spiritual hours or whatever like like
it's like did you know on this day yeah
[Applause]
like [ __ ] you still don't know that i
don't do taxes
[Laughter]
it's just like a real friendship with
you
gonna get baby text like did you know at
six months yourself this is how they
developed
when did you become like a google
assistant
yeah
it's hilarious so funny do you remember
that uh did you ever get i mean you guys
all used aim right i'm sure yeah yeah
but
i don't know if you didn't have friends
and you like or they were all
smarter you could smarter a child
smarter child smarter child
gina smarter child was his uh the
username smarter child on aim and
whatever you type it responds
immediately someone wrote like a a a
program or whatever that um just
responds immediately to like oh how are
you hi i'm doing great how are you today
i think you're a dick well that's not
really nice i don't like that at all and
it responds like immediately so it's
like a siri back then yeah like it's
like the first version of that yeah like
ai because yeah yeah like ai
but people just like it's like a program
script that they how did i miss that i
don't know i never knew you weren't
lonely enough if you had like an actual
social life yeah because for me i was
like my only friends are online and then
when they're not online i'll talk to a
smarter child oh jesus christ lady yeah
sometimes see why watching me and i'm
playing jeopardy with alexa oh my god
the funny thing about that is you have
friends that you like but you know what
she likes
[Music]
let's go i don't want to hear about your
life i don't want to hear about you or
what's going on here i want to play a
game for two minutes just guess the word
damn it
that's hilarious whatever
i like like i i like that like i've i've
heard people who just like get angry you
know like why are you hanging out with
your boyfriend not me it's just
something dude i told you guys before i
had friends that literally broke up with
me because i started dating casey
they're like we had a we had a meeting
at a lunch they're like you know what
you're not hanging out with us anymore i
remember this you're just hanging out
with your friend with your new boyfriend
yeah and like i don't i feel like you
just used us whoa
use them for what like
because i didn't have a man in my so i
tried
the previous times i've talked about
this i
understood their point but now at this
point i understood their point where i
was like maybe i was being a shitty
friend i understand that no because at
the same time it's like you should be
happy that your friend found someone
that maybe yeah and especially if it's a
new relationship but their higher
maintenance friends is what i found out
so then they didn't feel loved by me
they felt they ended up telling me how
they felt a lot of women do just
entirely drop their friends which is not
healthy for yeah other reasons yeah i
don't think i did break up with you like
that that's weird no but like when i was
dating him though i i didn't do that
like i still connected but we were
hanging out every single weekend like we
were when i was single oh yeah and then
so i felt like they just it's because
they still
they still do that like they they get
with their man and they still go out
clubbing every single weekend okay
sometimes their man joins them sometimes
they don't but mostly though it's like a
group of girlfriends that
it's like it's strong and they're really
involved even i wouldn't want to hang
out and go to the club every time like
that's too much like i know groups of
girls are like oh yeah we go to all
these events together and we all have
matching outfits and we all take
it's like jesus christ guys yeah that's
that's a bit much i don't want any of
that i don't like that's why like i see
i've seen wedding pictures of brides who
had like 17 bridesmaids and it's like
yeah it's all really like [ __ ] i
don't believe that they're all really
frustrated my friends that i'm talking
about literally no that happened no
yeah i don't believe i really like each
other that much like that much like that
like each and every one of you i don't
know i mean
like i said those friends are really
high maintenance because that's kind of
what happened with that
wedding too is from when i found out
about the other girls that were part of
it they were like oh my goodness yes
wild you know what else i realized
though is that so i never had a big
group of girlfriends that were like you
know i never understood big groups of
girls like that like right i never felt
like i could fit into that well it's not
super common yeah but like
those that type of outgoing like high
maintenance friends the ones that are um
that gina and i are talking about that
are like high school like close besties
this one is high school friends okay
yeah yeah but so for me i realized i was
like why
were are we like able to
like stay the same like where we like
really feel the same way like we don't
really really text each other or
whatever and when we see each other it's
great um i don't know if this is
relevant but they're all somewhat on the
spectrum too i realized like that um
they
either have adhd or they are
uh yeah
well do you know you well i mean genie
definitely have you ever had an
assessment
no i don't the third time this month i
tweeted something like does anyone else
do this and everyone's like
hey sweetheart you should probably look
into adulthood hd um
i
i i have trouble finishing tasks like
yes okay yes i'm gonna go do laundry and
then i find a sock oh that suck matches
what i'm looking for
oh hey there's a chair here that i
haven't i should look that up and see
how much it is yeah yes i do that and
then there was there's a bird outside
and i'm like that bird has yellow
feathers like what the [ __ ] bird is that
and then that bird i'm like that's a
yellow rusted chat okay cool and then
someone's like have you heard of a
heartbeat what the [ __ ] is that yeah oh
my god a heartbeat could be the size of
you and it could rip your [ __ ] face
off oh my god but have you seen the
philippine eagle oh my god yeah there it
is he looks like a guy doing cosplay as
an eagle it's [ __ ] scary there's
definitely a link between autism and
bird watching
i never liked birds until here because
there's so many different birds in this
neighborhood and i mean i didn't not
like birds but i wasn't really into them
yeah until like there was so many
different birds and i'm like googling
all the time and then i like looked up a
whole list of what birds are in nevada
like all the birds in nevada see so i
could figure out like on the spot where
they are yeah but i did that with the
royal family and then i was like i went
back to the place
three hours
so it's like i was supposed to do the
dishes and instead the whole garden's
clean my cat's shaved and like
dishes are still piled they're still
there exactly i tweeted that and people
were like i almost responded to that
tweet and then i saw the people already
answering like yeah they she got it yeah
one person even said
i know you're smarter than to take
advice from people on the internet but i
am a i'm a teacher that works with you
know kids whatever
you should probably look into adhd and
then i saw my replies an hour later i
was like oh [ __ ]
and then um i also saw another thing
that um i struggle with object
permanence what's that so like like a
baby yeah i do like a [ __ ] baby
so like like i'll be like let's see
that's nicki's thing
i gotta go buy some some like um some
glue sticks so i go buy glue stick okay
cool do my thing put it away a couple
weeks later i need a glue stick
i don't know where i put the so i forget
that i put it somewhere i'm like oh i
need to buy some glue sticks so i'll go
buy some more glue stick put it away and
then i just get a whole pile of blue
sticks
in a drawer and it's like 57 glitches
exactly so they're like yeah that's a
sign of adhd i was like
are you in a room and then you forgot
why you're in that room like because
yeah but you've been in that room for
like 45 minutes thinking about a
thousand different things and then
you're like why the [ __ ] did i even walk
in here like what did i need in here my
body came here because it needed
something and then i don't remember and
then i leave the room and then five
minutes like oh i gotta that's what i i
think i wanna see when i go up up the
stairs a lot of people don't do that
are you there for like 45 minutes
thinking about it no i wouldn't wait 45
minutes
i was in the cupboard of my kitchen like
for like 15 minutes thinking about 10
different things googling things on my
phone and i'm still in the cupboard like
my hands still moving things and then
i'm like what am i looking for in the
cupboard coffee creamer which is in the
fridge
i was like i don't even need this
cupboard i stood in the middle of the g4
hallway once just frozen because i
couldn't remember where i wanted to go
and i didn't want to do anything to lose
the yeah it's right there
like and then our pee because you gotta
sneeze but yeah yeah so rp comes over
he's like are you okay
and like another pa comes over like my
executive comes over you okay i'm trying
to remember something and like i said in
the bathroom and then i realized oh i
was gonna go shave my armpits i'm
wearing a tank top today
you know i heard i read something about
when that happens when you have like
something in the tip of your tongue to
put like to lower your head like what
like you have to bend over now i want to
be the [ __ ] child
what you actually have to do is just
move on to the next thing and then
you'll immediately remember what it was
so steve and i have gotten into
arguments about this because he thinks
i'm shooing him away like shushing him
when he needs me for something but i'll
be like a bit like this like and staring
at something and like visualizing and
then forgetting and trying to remember
what i was visualizing and then he'll
come in and go like good morning and
he'll try to give me a hug
and i can't even like say the english
words i'm just like
yeah
and he's like okay in japanese he gets
really sad about it and i'm like i'm not
so personal like my brain is like
literally it's actually like i wish i
could just be normal but it just can't
and it's just if i don't remember it and
then what if it was important i don't
even remember if it's important or not
like what if it wasn't yeah yeah and now
i'm gonna lose it exactly probably isn't
important but yeah i don't have those
thoughts and i also like i can't that's
why i don't watch movies i don't go
watch movies because they can't sit
there the whole time and just you know i
have to like be on my phone i have to be
doing something i can watch movies
because i get hyper focused on what's
going on in the story also
what happens though is what distracts me
from movies is if there's a hole in the
[ __ ] plot like if there's like
something like they [ __ ] miss and
then i'm like why didn't they when they
just wait why didn't they just do that
why are they moving on they didn't do
that why didn't they just check this
continuity
i'm like what the [ __ ] like or they'll
leave the room and they left the door
open but then the next the next frame
you see the door closed i'm like when
the [ __ ] did they close the door like
what who is the script so yeah
i see that a lot more now since you
started pointing stuff out i just like
casually notice things more now
their hair
like how does that that's what i'm like
that would be my job
sometimes they lose the prop like they
lost that pillow and they're like oh you
the other pillow and it's not the same
dude i would obsess over it when we
would be shooting the jk skits i'm like
no no what's up here yeah yeah g4
because we have like a talk show sort of
thing it's gotten to the point where
they have fidget toys for us and then
our audience realized like we have when
we have fidget toys we focus way more
and we can actually pay attention more
we just got a whole box of fidget toys
from from one of our fans like a week
ago nice yeah so now i'm just like
that's what i was telling steve i was
trying to explain this that how i have
to be doing two things at once in order
to focus on the first thing yeah because
i if i'm only doing the one thing and my
brain is distracted in five other areas
i usually have headphones on because if
i have music playing the song takes the
place of the second activity
and when i'm driving i need to like have
i need to be singing along to the music
but like even if it's just lightly like
i don't even have to be like blasting
singing along but just like i need to be
just like
singing the lyrics to the song so i
could focus on driving the only times
i've ever hit somebody are when i was
driving with my eyes straight ahead with
no music on no phone nothing that's the
only times i've hit someone
yeah so now i'm like i should probably
go get evaluated
true yeah is this the adh thing or ocd i
don't know
they're all i do the umbrella of
neurodiversity so i do this thing that
drives casey [ __ ] crazy and i
understand why but i do this thing that
every time the food is ready for me to
eat or
i
need to eat like i'm [ __ ] hungry like
i feel like i'm going to pass out
because i haven't eaten i have to do a
million things before i i feed myself
oh that's not just like some childhood
thing or like oh could be a cd like what
do you do like what are you doing though
so like for example because he's like do
you feel like you have to earn it or
whatever
yeah i told him that i'm like i feel
like i think i need to earn the food or
something i don't know because for
example he'll have dinner ready and then
he's like okay food's ready and i come
downstairs and then i'm gonna get a fork
and then i realize like the dishwasher
is completely like clean but full so i'm
like putting the dishes away and then
i'm like oh wait there's this package
that just came in let me open this
package like wait before you're gonna
eat yeah and the food's on the table
what the [ __ ] no i don't know for me and
he's mad because the food's getting cold
i'm casey getting mad because i like to
eat like when food is ready yeah but
okay if i have that thing where like i'm
like if steve's not home if i'm just
eating and my food's ready um and then
there's a package that comes i'm like
taking the food with me and eating like
the food while i'm opening the package
and if i'm alone and like the food's
like usually if i'm alone and i'm hungry
and i need to feed myself there is food
that isn't like there's no food ready i
need to go and make the food i will
prevent myself from even making my food
and do a million things yeah i
definitely order post mates do you think
that it's a distraction like food like
the food the sitting down and eating
food was like a difficult process for
you as a child so i definitely
definitely have food trauma like so
you're maybe you're like you're kind of
like still avoiding the process of
eating yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no yeah
cause like i would i was being force-fed
whenever yeah like when you have to when
you have children that are like you sit
at this table and you don't [ __ ] do
anything until you eat like that could
be like a
you're avoiding it but you don't even
need to now because you're a grown adult
you can't get what you want you can do
it if you don't want so then that has
always been like a point of contention
in our relationship casey would be so
mad and like just we'll be happy like
finally i sit down and eat like we're
eating and then i'm all over here like
whatever and he's just like fuming
because he's like [ __ ] cold and i'm
like
i just wouldn't get it you're still like
rebelling against having us to like sit
down and eat food because yeah forced
you to or something but then like now i
like i tell him i'm like okay if i'm
doing it like point it out and then so
he'll like now he'll point out be like
oh you're doing it again i'm like oh
[ __ ] okay let me stop can you just
imagine you sitting at the dinner table
and just like hit the knife against the
table like
hello
poor thing
yeah
even when i'm cooking or eating too i
wonder you should talk to him because i
don't know if it's the same he doesn't
have any food problems but he needs to
like wash his hands and like sometimes
he needs to like usually wash the hands
before you well yeah but like he goes
and washes his hands but he takes like
20 minutes i don't know what he's doing
other than the washing the hands but it
takes so long to get to the freaking
table by the time he gets there my food
i'm already done eating because i don't
wait for him yeah if he's because he's
maybe he's distracted and he's like
looking at his face i have no idea but
i'm like there's [ __ ] food how are
you not trying to eat the food
you fat
yeah i even do that too like when i'm
trying to cook a meal i don't know why
it takes me more than an hour to like
make something simple where i'm like
what the [ __ ] i tried i really tried to
make it rice no like to i don't know
makes make something for breakfast i'm
like yeah how did a whole hour go by i
was rushing i was doing it i was doing
everything in the whole [ __ ] hour i
have definitely started boiling water
for my oatmeal in the morning and it
takes like five minutes to boil because
it's just like a little amount of water
so five minutes to boil and then i leave
the room and i totally get distracted
and then i come back to like a burning
saucepan
smoking and then i'm like oh i'm not
gonna keep my water again and then i do
it like three more times
our fridge because you have to like push
the button to heat the water and then
we'll walk away and then it like stops
and then you have to get really doing it
i do that with laundry i washed it oh
[ __ ] forgot to drive yes and then it's
gonna wash it again
your [ __ ] washing machine is probably
disgusting yeah it's just oh yeah we
need to get it clean this is why this is
why i hire people to do things i set
alarms for everything i have to set
alarms for everything if i'm like if i
have a meeting i set it up 10 minutes
before the meeting and then there's like
if i had started the laundry i have to
set an alarm for 30 minutes from now i
ask alexa to do a lot of it like to
because i'm usually at home but if i'm
not at home or if i'm doing my makeup or
something i have to like set like alarms
and like if i'm meeting somebody like
i've gone out with to brunch with our
neighbors a few times where they ordered
an uber and they're like okay the uber's
gonna be here at 10 45 okay so i set an
alarm for 10 35 because that at that
point like i need to know that i'm
pretty ready to go at 10 35 and i gotta
look for my keys or whatever miss things
that take like 10 minutes but then i
also have an alarm for 30 minutes before
that to like tell me like if you haven't
started getting ready for by now you
need to start getting ready right now
and then i have an um
i definitely have like three or four oh
that's every minute yeah
do you ever forget what the alarm was
for because that happens to me no i put
labels on it so i have labels on mine
but i don't change the label so
sometimes it's like post for disney and
that was like in february of last year
no i definitely have multiple alarms but
every night before i go to bed i set
alarms for each thing so if i have a
meeting at three it's like there's a
couple alarms before three yeah if i
have something to do at seven there's a
couple alarms before seven so every day
it's like
a lazy ass so i need like the first one
yeah yeah
exactly if you're sleeping on a terrible
mattress your sleep will be terrible
it's that simple that's why i recommend
sleeping on a purple mattress that's
because only purple mattresses have the
gel flux grid it's a super stretchy
ultra squishy material that adapts and
flexes around pressure points and
doesn't retain heat the gel flex grid is
amazingly supportive for your back and
legs while cushioning your shoulders
neck and hips no matter how you sleep
unlike memory foam which remembers
everything the gel flex grid purple
mattresses bounce back as you move and
shift you'll never have that i'm stuck
feeling people get with memory foam try
your purple mattress risk free with free
shipping and returns financing is also
available nikki actually has his bed in
her guest room and i slept in it and it
was so good i'm actually jealous
and i want one now getting a great
night's sleep starts with having a great
mattress so get a purple mattress go to
purple.com big mood 10 and use code big
moo 10 for a limited time you can get 10
off any order of 200 or more that's
purple.com big mood 10 code big mood 10
for 10 off any order of two hundred
dollars or more again that's purple.com
slash big mood 10 promo code big mood 10
terms apply with all the questionable
materials and baby products these days
parenting can be scary
if you want to keep your baby safe and
protected without sacrificing their
comfort with coterie your baby can have
both the cleanest and highest performing
diapers with a comfortable feel
i am such a ginormous huge huge huge fan
of coterie diapers i have been having my
baby luca wear coterie diapers for like
the past couple months now and i am
telling you these diapers are such high
quality they literally have like a cloth
like material like clothing grade
material which gives my baby this
cashmere like feel and he's never been
this comfortable with other diapers that
we've tried in the past because you know
they kind of get a little itchy they get
wet really fast like he's just not
comfortable he wants to get his diaper
changed really quick but with cotery he
stays dry
faster because coterie has up to four
times faster moisture wicking versus
other brands and up to two times more
liquid capacity so my baby has been
staying drier longer
and other coterie parents just like
myself report fewer nighttime diaper
changes which can lead to better sleep
quality not just for your baby but for
you too and i can definitely attest to
this my baby stays with his cotery
diaper from the moment that we put him
to sleep to the moment that he wakes up
in the morning he literally does not
need a diaper change the entire night
i'm so mind blown because with my other
big baby now who's now 14 back then
diapers were nowhere near as capable as
coterie is now like i'm just mind blown
at how far diaper technology has gone
i'm such a huge fan you guys coterie has
been awarded best diaper and wipes by
both the bump and parents.com so forget
about nighttime leaks and wet sheets and
try the rolls royce of diapers cotery
right now coterie is partnering with our
podcast to offer you 20 off your first
order plus free shipping at
codery.com
big mood that's codery spelled c o t e r
i e
com big mood for 20 off and free
shipping
codery.com slash big mood dude i don't
need alarms anymore now you don't no i
have luca luco
yeah i'm like okay cool because i used
to set alarms but now i'm like oh i'll
definitely be up at four i'll be up at
seven yeah
i just know my distracted ass will get
like the 10 minutes away from alarm and
then like i will get distracted by
something else so i need like a two
minutes away alarm so what do you do
with adhd what am i supposed to do so
talk to a psychologist or psychiatrist
or a psychologist either one but
psychiatrists can prescribe you
medication if that's what they feel you
need like and i had an appointment with
one that she ran me through several
different ones that might work for me
and she also asked me a bunch of
questions because i'm personally on
adderall and i like that but she was
asking me like do you plan to get
pregnant in the next year do you have
depression do you have other symptoms
because some of them don't work well
with other medications personally i'm
not on any other medication i don't even
like taking advil or tylenol or anything
i take vitamins though right i do take
vitamins but i don't take like like
pharmaceutical drugs like i don't take
birth control i don't yeah like
psychoactive or hormonal yeah nothing
that's gonna mess with any of my system
um so
uh for me adderall was seemed like the
best fit because my blood pressure was
low it's actually below average and uh
if you have like an above average blood
pressure it's not gonna work for you
it's like speed uh yeah i guess they say
that but here's the thing if a non of
someone that doesn't need it like
someone without atd takes it they're
like up cleaning all the time you hear
those stories like
i've literally taken
a two hour long naps after taking
adderall because for me my brain's crazy
hyperactive it's thinking a thousand
thoughts at the same time they're all
meshing together they're all like
crashing into each other they're in like
a big cloud and adderall like calms them
all down puts them in a line and it's
like someone described it as glasses for
your brain that's exactly what it feels
like it feels like everything is blurry
i can't focus on anything i can't get
anything done and i don't know which one
to start at because they're all on the
same priority and they're all asking for
my attention at the same time and then
outer like puts it in a line and then i
just do one thing at a time and i'm like
that is crazy that people just can do
one thing at a time yeah and for me it's
the smallest dosage it is five
milligrams
it is the perfect amount um it lasts for
about four hours and then i just do it
to get through if i have a long to do
list then i get through my to-do list
and i'm like okay i don't need it
anymore i don't mind having a million
thoughts if it because it does help me
creatively as a creative person having a
lot of ideas is great but
executing those ideas is really hard if
you can't like focus that's what i've
always said i'm great at ideas but not
executing yeah gina there we go i'm your
psychiatrist
but yeah they'll be able to really
officially yeah they need to know
everything i definitely need to talk to
them because there's like a lot of
history that you might have that i
didn't have um for me she was bringing
up several other prescriptions that are
more like long-term you have to take
them every day i like adderall because i
only take them when i need to focus and
that my brain isn't focusing and like
can't focus i used to have a lot of
anxiety attacks because i couldn't get
i was overwhelmed by my to-do list and i
couldn't get things done and i also felt
broken as a human being that i wasn't
able to like get them done and i would
cry and i would feel so
worthless because like i don't know it's
always been very drilled into me that
productivity and
efficiency is like
something to strive for and is number
one and that's like how you were
successful is by getting everything done
and the fact that i just couldn't
[ __ ] put it in line or get it done by
a deadline like made me feel really sad
and broken about myself and then i
realized that i have 80d and like it
really solved a lot of things and i um
getting on medication helped so much
because it's still me i'm just able to
focus on one thing at a time and not
getting distracted by a billion other
things and then when i don't need it
like if it's a weekend and i don't have
to do anything really like maybe i want
to do gardening or something but i don't
have to i don't take it because i don't
need it so it's really just to get [ __ ]
done that's the problem too it's like i
get so overwhelmed because i did one
thing and then another but i never
finished anything that i get overwhelmed
i just get saddened down yeah yeah you
like yourself
that's what i do too yeah and like my
therapist she like she had recommended
for me to seek a psychiatrist because i
told her that i always
like
by me describing how i view life she's
like you should probably seek a
psychiatrist because i said i feel like
i'm always walking through tar like i
can't move that sounds like a chemical
imbalance yeah and then i told her i'm
like but sometimes she's like do you
ever feel like you're not walking a tar
i'm like sometimes it feels like i'm
walking in water yeah like it's like
still like not yeah out of
something and so she said like i should
probably see it but i haven't because i
kind of have like
like i don't know anxiety about it
because when i was little
when i was 11 my mom had taken me to
psychiatrist and she did medicate me and
all these years i always thought it was
one month on medication because she i
thought that like that's what i
registered that i was on medication for
just one month and then just last week i
just found out that i was actually on
two medications for a whole year i was
like you blacked out the rest of the
year yeah i didn't know this i was on
paxil for depression and ritalin for 80
years as an 11 year old that's so long
and she told me that like i the reason
why she got me off of it i forgot to
tell you this case but
the reason why she took me off of it is
because and this part i did know is
because
i ended up turning into like a zombie i
was not the same person anymore i was
just like [ __ ] like drugged out like
crazy
and the other reason which i didn't know
was the fact that i became angry i was
having anger issues and i was like
rageful and she said that that was a
common symptom with
ritalin so she took me off of that or
paxil she didn't know which one it was
so the mixture yeah yeah so then i was
like is that why i have anger issues now
like i feel like i can't control my
emotions a lot of the times and i feel
like i'm just like
i sometimes see red when i'm mad
i don't do anything really but like i
i don't know like the energy right right
like
a lot more than just the medication
though too that's just like a symptom of
like how you learn how to handle things
is like whatever it is you didn't learn
how to so yeah so angry yeah
for sure but then um i definitely did
feel a shift in yeah and like how i am
as a person yeah because i remember
before being on medication the way i was
like i was i was a lot more fidgety a
lot more like talkative i was way more
talkative than if if you think i'm
talkative now like oh my god no i could
not stop talking before and then after
being on the medication like i was able
to actually like sit still like i'm able
to now sit still and like not have to
talk that much i can be quiet and
it definitely completely like
changed your personality it changed me
to my core yeah well your now still
developing it so then that's right now
like when i'm being referred to a
psychiatrist i'm like
i don't know you have a fully formed
brain yeah so it's different than like
dude 11 to like your teen pre-teen and
teenage years you're like developing in
so many ways your brain's developing and
then also your hormones are like going
different ways and like everything is
before i got my period yeah it's like
that's that area of time is like so yeah
and it takes a long time to figure out
which medication would actually work for
you so you could spend like three years
figuring out and like going through
different side effects and symptoms from
those wrong medications yeah and then
like if you turn into a zombie if you
turn into a zombie that's the wrong
medication right or the wrong dosage or
something then you'll have to switch to
another medication and then you have to
wait three to six months to see if that
one works out that could you could feel
like [ __ ] that whole time you're gonna
switch again and you're gonna keep
trying yes because they're all just
guessing
yeah
it's a it's a long
i'm like i'll
like i can't there's nothing else i can
do in life but if you're like i'm at
home and taking care of my son things
are generally fine like maybe it's not
worth all of that yeah that long process
it would take to maybe feel 25 percent
happier i don't know yeah for me i felt
i needed something because i was going
insane and having pain attacks and like
and i have i maybe have like two panic
attacks a year now i was having them
like twice a week before yeah too many
definitely too many yeah i just felt
like there was so much on my plate i
couldn't get it done i felt like [ __ ]
like then i would go into a depression
spiral because
i couldn't get anything done and then
that would make me not get more things
done and
um another thing that i didn't know was
add related uh gina i don't know if you
go through this but um there's it's poor
executive function where like i have to
she definitely has poor executives yeah
i have to get up and
i have to get up and do something right
now i have to go i have to get up and
um i have to go meet someone in 15
minutes and i know i need to get up and
do a couple things first and i can't
get my body to go like it just won't i
can just i'm like come on we gotta go
yeah and it just won't [ __ ] go
you have that
shocker
shocker
all that's every day
like every day yeah it's poor executive
function
oh
yeah the other part that i also like i
kept learning more and more i'm like
whoa this filled in so many gaps that
made me feel so broken for so long that
like i didn't know was all related to
one thing of like my brain working
differently um so the other thing is
like do you ever get these feelings
where like
you feel like you need something like
you need something but you don't know
what you're just like
i need
i need i don't know what i need like i
need you but i need something it's like
a i guess it's a we get we have lower
serotonin or
some not dope is either dopamine or
serotonin one of those things but it's
like a shortage of that
thing that is like satisfying or
fulfilled and so you just feel like you
need to fill it with something but you
don't know what so you like
maybe take a cigarette or you maybe take
like a snack like i i filled it with
food for a while but it's not
the food doesn't do anything i just
still need something but i don't know
what
that's that too
oh [ __ ] yeah i feel what it's called it
has like a a label to it
okay yeah all right well that convinced
me
i'm gonna go find a psychiatrist well
i'm glad we made some discovery yeah oh
my god imagine if i start getting on the
right medication i become [ __ ]
president of america
i'm unstoppable i honestly feel like you
could you could do so much more like
you're just so capable but i do feel
like something like it's probably just
that executive function thing where it's
like
how smart you are and how creative you
are and how like everything you are just
letting it get into a line like filling
for me
adderall helped immensely like totally
changed my life but it's not like i'm
not like go get out or all like i don't
know like i take the small could be
something else it could be it's like a
different type of help me like get every
oh there's like the missing thing that
like helped me get all my stuff done
like where i was able to actually focus
and do it and do things um and like not
have that executive function thing but
um for some people like my therap my
psychiatrist recommended a couple
different ones and she was like
depending on what
what fits your lifestyle more and like
compared to like the history that you've
had one of them was like also an
antidepressant because i had mentioned
depression and stuff too and she was
asking me questions about that but i was
like
well i don't really feel like i feel
like the depression is a is caused by
all this anxiety and then feeling like i
disappointed myself and like feeling
like i'm a piece of [ __ ] so it comes it
comes from a sense it's like a domino
effect it's not just there
yeah just there but yeah after when i
was able to get things done i don't it
doesn't spiral into depression like it
used to
i do get waves like some days i wake up
and i'm like i don't feel good today but
it's very it's very rare i don't know we
just get those questions anyway yeah i
also realized uh this year that i might
have pmdd which is like
an extreme form of pms yeah because like
the three days before my period i feel
like i want to die like i just i'm like
there's no point to the world like none
of this matters i need to die like i
just don't want to not exist anymore
it's really extreme and i'm very like
frustrated by every little thing like
every sound every like the brightness of
the room like everything is so extreme
to me like i can hear my cat cleaning
itself like across the room and i'm like
i can't handle that noise right now like
shut the door i can't handle it yeah
everything is like
so like my blood is boiling like it's so
irritating that like my blood starts
boiling and i was telling my therapist
and she was like i think like you should
track when this happens because if it's
around your period you should talk to
your ob gyn about whether or not you
have pmdd and like they can like maybe
prescribe you stuff but i haven't gone
that far yet
because it really is only those three
days but um yeah it's pretty extreme
well and just understanding yourself
better really helps because like now
when i get that away i'm like
what time of the month is it so you know
it's like no it's like no no reason
whatsoever yeah alarm injury reminders
yeah
well my cycle's also really short it's
like 21 days so it's not even like on
the calendar alexa said an alarm for
every 21 days right yeah yeah remind me
to not be telling me
every 21 days hey your peers coming i'm
your friend
i'm your friend i'm your friend
or well let us know in the comments what
you think like are you a high
maintenance friend are you a
low-maintenance friend do you have a
teeth
does that affect you
yeah
[ __ ] i can't wait for you to talk to
somebody about it yeah yeah
well i had to book your flight here
maybe i should book your appointment
just do it for her until she gets on her
feet seriously right her ocd helps her
yeah
we fit each other so well together so
good so funny oh my god yeah casey was
like i think gina needs an assistant i'm
like even if she had an assistant she
wouldn't tell the assistant
she didn't need someone to do this stuff
without her asking
it's really true
that's what you could spend your money
on they've been hoarding all these years
seriously yeah
oh my god yeah support luca is a college
fund there you go
she doesn't even remember to pay herself
no oh yeah they're like hey take your
paycheck this month and then two months
go by i'm like hey take two paychecks
all right thank you guys we love you
wait is it over yeah
sponsored
[Music]
you